I'm going to be speaking with Robert Fatalis,
who is professor of political science at the
University of Pennsylvania and also author
of the book Oil Craft The Myths of Scarcity
and Security That Haunt US Energy Policy.
So great to have you on.
I think at the time of a presidential transition
where there are questions about if and how
policy will change around oil, it's a it's
a very timely conversation.
Thanks.
It's great to be here.
So I guess to start with, when you talk about
oil craft or the trick that is sometimes played
with the topic of oil, like what is the big
trick?
What's the big misunderstanding?
Well, the big misunderstanding is that you
don't have to do anything special to guarantee
access to it, especially during peacetime,
meaning there's a world market in oil.
One just buys it.
That is how the military gets its oil.
That is how all domestic refiners get their
oil.
So all talk about need to use military power
to secure access or against threats are pretty
much untrue.
And can you talk a little bit about why?
So there's there's probably some people who
will hear you say that and they'll say, OK,
well, there's an aspect of that that makes
intuitive sense.
But at the same time, the world wouldn't necessarily
grind to a halt if access to a different commodity
like pork bellies were somehow impacted.
It seems as though because so much transportation
depends on oil, so many products, including
products that have plastic, come from oil
and so many different things, it seems that
the implications are different.
Even if on paper we're talking about two commodities,
why do you argue that there is not really
a difference?
Because the vision of access somehow being
denied by some crisis is also something that
hasn't existed in in our lives.
So, for instance, right now, access is being
hindered in all sorts of way to oil supplies,
but we hardly think about it.
What is the perfect example of that?
The United States government has sanctions
on various governments that are oil producers.
Venezuela on the one hand, Iran on the other,
that hinders access in in real ways.
But we don't talk about it.
Instead, what we imagine is some kind of,
I don't know, like a disaster movie where
all oil, all oil production collapses.
We've never had an experience like that.
But we we generate constant, scary scenarios.
One of the global relationships that uses
oil as a justification for being sort of a
special relationship or one that needs to
be treated differently is the U.S. relationship
with Saudi Arabia.
And sometimes if you step back, it might be
sort of confusing, given the democratic values
that so many administrations have claimed
to want to spread around the world and in
fact, many of the military conflicts based
on spreading those ideas.
It would seem counterintuitive that we would
have the relationship we do with Saudi Arabia,
which represents much of what we seek to change
in that region and elsewhere in the world.
But oil and a shared goal of stability in
the region is often cited as the explanation.
How does your perspective on oil modify how
maybe we should be thinking of that relationship?
Well, one that is correct.
Oil is used as the explanation for what we
ostensibly otherwise would not do.
Right.
So and, you know, basically that's another
scary scenario to that has that have trip
that has tripped people in the past.
So Americans who otherwise would not think
we have some kind of we should be so closely
involved with Saudi Arabia except OK, but
we need their oil.
And and so we have to kind of swallow our
pride or not pursue our more idealistic side.
And that's fundamentally incorrect, as my
favorite oil economist of the 1970s said back
then, and it remains true until now, the one
thing Saudi Arabia has to do is sell their
oil on the world market.
The one thing we don't have to worry about
is access to oil from Saudi Arabia or anyone
else has has to worry about.
Are there other relationships.
So you mentioned Venezuela.
We know about the relationship with Saudi
Arabia.
Are there other geopolitical alliances or
relationships that that are important when
it comes to oil that are much less discussed
in media and that people may not understand
the role of?
Well, I think, folks, you can just think about
the US position in the Persian Gulf, generally,
not just in Saudi Arabia, but in.
Bahrain, where the Fifth Fleet is located
in Qatar, in the Emirates and and so forth,
we have this understanding that we have to
be in the Persian Gulf to protect access to
oil.
And what I've argued and what the military
has said time and time again in other experts
is that that is incorrect.
And so the real question should be, so what's
behind that, behind the rationale of strategic
access to oil?
What do these regimes actually do for us that
that keep us so closely tied to them?
I want to get to eventually in our conversation,
some of the reasons why we've not moved off
of oil more quickly.
But before addressing that, because there
are so many geopolitical relationships that
are connected to oil, there are significant,
it would seem, diplomatic and foreign policy
implications that would that would rise if
indeed the U.S. and the world were to accelerate
getting off of oil and towards renewable energy
and other types of energy sources.
Is that intuition accurate in a sense, or
do you believe that there would simply be
new justifications given for maintaining the
status quo, which now oil is pointed to as
the explanation?
I'm you know, I'm usually trust professors
to predict anything.
But of course, that said, I lean toward your
second option there.
Right.
Other rationales will be created to continue
to pursue the policies that we pursue now
that whatever else they do have no impact
on, on access to oil.
We have a perfect example of this.
The United States is has has a large military
presence in the Persian Gulf.
In the past weeks, Saudi oil facilities or
oil transport have been bombed by ships.
And and the US is unable to to prevent the
precise kinds of threats that we often think
is at the heart of our military presence there.
But does the the military want to stay there?
Absolutely.
All else equal the military presence is a
benefit to the military.
They've never been really behind any kind
of a retreat from positions where they already
secured what would be the and again, maybe
I'm asking for a prediction or maybe maybe
we have a reason to think one way or the other
if the excuse of oil were no longer credible
in terms of explaining a U.S. Saudi relationship,
that doesn't seem to make much sense for the
reasons we discussed earlier.
What do you imagine would replace it as the
justification will eat?
Well, whether it would work or not, whether
Americans would come to say, OK, yes, we have
to do it, we have to accept our ties to the
Saudis.
We have no other choice.
Well, one is a new one.
This is the one credit I give to Mohammed
bin Salman, the de facto ruler, which is that
also to be a it's a it's a it's a plus on
the side of Israel.
And those Americans who really think it's
important that the Saudis are part of a coalition
with Israel against Iran.
Right.
And you notice in that discussion there's
no talk about oil or the oil disappears.
Right.
And in fact, we'd be better off if Iran was
producing its oil unhindered by the United
States.
It's of course, it's, of course, producing
oil, but it's doing it with the assistance
of China at this point.
OK, so when we think about why we've not moved
away from oil more quickly, we seem to have
the technological know how to do it to a greater
degree than it has has been done.
And there are all sorts of explanations that
are often given.
Some are more foreign policy related, including
what you and I have been talking about.
Some claim that we simply don't have the efficiency
in some of these alternatives to oil to generate
the energy we need, that while solar panels
are improving and wind is improving, we're
simply not there yet.
And there's a debate about that.
And it seems that to a great extent it's not
true is part about political willingness to
do it.
But but maybe to some degree we're not quite
there.
There are other explanations given as well
in terms of will.
It would damage this industry well, but it
would prop this one up.
And then you have to kind of balance whether
it would be a net job creator or destroyer.
If you had to give us a general assessment
of why we've not moved away from oil more
quickly, what would it include?
A political will?
I think the obfuscating arguments of multiple,
you know, vested interests in this process.
I've watched this, I've studied how these
debates took place in the 1970s during the
so-called energy crisis, and there was a lot
of confusion out there because to people of
different interests tend to argue their positions.
They tend to exaggerate, you know, the the
significance or the or the or the importance
or the security threats to their various positions.
So I think lack of political will.
Yes, the technology is not completely there
yet.
But at the same time, I've noticed something
are happening for the first time, which is
the oil industry itself, or at least the largest
segments of the oil industry.
The global the global producers are arguing,
in fact, they are preparing for a peak, not
supply, which is how we used to talk about
it, but peak demand that in fact, their predictions
are oil demand for oil will be declining over
the medium term, etc..
So I think something is happening.
And what do they say would be the the catalysts
for those declines in demand?
Concerns about global warming, the environment
and the committee commitments on, I mean,
the commitments of various domestic groups
to the fears of what climate change mean,
plus the plus the developments in the technology.
That's what economists have said.
At some point, oil will oil will simply become
a wasted asset that will remain in the ground
because technology will shift such that we
can we we will have a better energy source
sources to rely on.
So along those lines, the President Trump,
the one that still president for a few more
days, he has said many times during his rallies
and during various briefings, even briefings
unrelated to energy as they often are, he
has uttered this this phrase that we are now
energy independent.
First question is, is that true?
And then a second question is, has fracking
impacted the U.S. energy picture in a significant
enough way that it has separated us a little
bit from the geopolitical oil situation?
OK, great questions.
No, we are not energy independent because
we live in a one world market for oil.
Right.
We believe, you know, we have this fiction.
We think that domestic sources of supply is
what the country first relies on.
And then and only then does it does it a turn
to export?
That has never been true, number one.
Number two, even to the extent that we are
now producing more oil through hydraulic fracturing
than we had in the then than we've had for
a long time, the price of that oil depends
on events in the world market.
So there is no way to stop the what drives
us most crazy in the day to day the volatility
and price of oil right now where prices are
down.
But we remember back when barrels of oil were
under two dollars.
Well, in the future, we are not able to put
up walls against those price shocks unless
we turn to a kind of a domestic politics that
we haven't seen in this country for decades,
which was which would be to create a new protectionist
regime.
Right.
Not permit any or not permit any imports of
oil and rely completely on domestic production.
Well, you know, that's been a failure in the
past.
It's caused all sorts of problems in the United
States.
And it's hard to imagine returning to that
now.
Has has fracking reduced our dependency?
No, because it's it's just not the case.
So there's one there's an easy way to see
that we can look at our oil import figures
and they're out.
We still imported oil.
Right, because certain users prefer the their
own refineries are geared toward certain kinds
of oil.
And it's very difficult for them to move away
from the oil that they tend to use.
Let me give you one good example that people
never think of.
Yeah, folks argued they expected that with
hydraulic fracturing, we would not any longer
be dependent on Saudi Arabia and Iran.
Imports from Saudi Arabia would decline.
Well, that's not true.
Why people forget that Saudi Arabia is itself
a major refiner in the United States.
The largest amount of Saudi oil coming to
the United States is to is to supply their
own refineries in the United States in the
same way that a global oil company like Exxon
would do.
So setting up refineries in various countries
in order to have guaranteed markets for their
crude, etc..
So Saudi Arabia continues to import Saudi
Arabian oil into Saudi refineries in the United
States.
Real quick, the last thing I wanted to touch
on and my my expectation is your commentary
on this would be more geopolitical than technological,
but I'm glad to hear your thoughts.
Either way, there are folks on the left who
are sometimes divided over the role of new
nuclear capacity and technology as a possible
bridge from the current paradigm to renewables.
And there are some who don't like the sort
of risk of nuclear.
While the more nuclear engineers I talk to,
the more they say that those risks are really
based on 40, 50 year old technology, which
is not what would be used if new nuclear was
put online.
So I'm sort of open to the idea of new nuclear
as a bridge, Mike.
Concern is that practically, because it takes
a while to bring that capacity on, it seems
it would be difficult to commit to it merely
being a bridge.
What is your sort of thought about new nuclear
as and its role?
Well, I think your your vision of that is
yours is mine.
It's I think is is the correct one.
And also what doesn't often get talked about
is the fact that those new nuclear plants
would be subsidized by the by government in
one form or another.
Right.
It's very hard to do it economically now without
subsidy.
So you can imagine another new industry seeking
know, seeking those subsidies in order to
in order to get new plants operational.
You know, the text I read on this question,
the debate is still open.
I've seen I've seen books by actually old
friends of mine from graduate school have
argued this is this is the only real way forward,
especially if what we care about is generating
electricity for the millions of people in
India and elsewhere that still have no electricity.
Renewables are not going to be able to to
to give the development that folks need around
the world.
And nuclear is the way to do that.
But I've also seen technologies challenge,
challenge that claim.
So I think what we're going to see is, I mean,
I can't resolve that right.
To see as more flights around that question.
And it's certainly there is certainly a visceral
argument against it on the part of the left.
And I think that goes back to, you know, back
to the 70s, to Chernobyl, to Three Mile Island
and so forth, to no nukes.
There was there were the concerns back then.
Right.
And the left is with you on this.
The left seems more or less committed to the
idea of green New Deal renewables supporting
fossil fuels or any other kind of industry
at the same time.
Yep, I agree.
An issue of critical importance and one, maybe
two to expand on in the future.
We've been speaking with Robert Fatalis, who's
a professor of political science at the University
of Pennsylvania, also author of the book Oil
Craft The Myths of Scarcity and Security That
Haunt US Energy Policy.
Thanks so much for your time today and take
good care of The David Pakman Show at David
Pakman Dotcom.